Ich bin der DS Habe, dass auch diese Station,
bevor über ihre Beschwerden sprechen, bräuchte ich ein paar allgemeine Informationen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Elke Sauter.
Können Sie Vor- und Nachname langsam buchstabieren?
Der Vorname ist kurz ELKE.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Sauter. S-A-U-T-E-R.
Elke Sauter.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Sauter?
Ich bin 60 Jahre gerade.
60 Jahre?
Okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. März 65.
65, okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege so 70 kg.
70 kg? Gut.
Und ich bin 1.64 groß.
1.64.
Mhm.
Welche Beschwerde haben Sie?
Ich habe solche Bauchschmerzen.
Mir ist so unglaublich schlecht.
Das fing gestern Abend an.
Ich musste mich schon dreimal übergeben.
Ich habe ständig Krämpfe im Bauch.
Seit heute Früh bin ich nur auf dem Weg zur Toilette.
Ich habe ständig Durchfall.
Es ist ganz hell rot.
Ich hatte gestern Abend Fieber.
Ich fühle mich total schla-
Sie haben gesagt, seit gestern Abend Bauchschmerzen haben.
Wo sind die genau Schmerzen?
Wie kann ich das sagen?
Um den Bauchnabel rum, in der Mitte vom Bauch.
Mitte vom Bauch, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Durchfall haben.
Seit heute Morgen renne ich nur noch auf die Toilette.
Wie viel haben Sie auf die Toilette gegangen?
Wie oft?
Ich habe das Gefühl, ständig.
4, 5, 6 Mal.
Okay.
Sie haben sich dreimal übergeben.
Danach habe ich mich immer kurzfristig leichter gefühlt.
Aber sofort ging es wieder los.
Die Schmerzen, manchmal geht es, manchmal kommt.
Das kann man so wählen, wissen Sie?
Ja.
Wie können Sie sich das machen?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich nicht mehr auf die Toilette gehe.
Wie können Sie sich die Schmerzen auf der Schmerzkala...
Wenn es gerade so ein Topf von so einer Welle ist,
dann ist das schon wirklich sehr heftig.
Sehr.
Von 1 bis 10 auf der Schmerzkala, 1 ist leichter, 10 unerträglich ist.
Man kann ja viel aushalten, aber bei 8, würde ich sagen, sind die Schmerzen schon.
8.
Können Sie bis Ende des Gesprächs die Schmerzen aushalten?
Das wird nämlich geblieben, ja.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie viel bei haben.
Haben Sie gemessen?
Ja, gestern Abend habe ich mich gemessen, da hatte ich 38.4.
38.4, okay.
Haben Sie gegen Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Nee, ich habe auch gar nichts im Haus, weil ich eigentlich nie Tabletten nehme.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein Auslöser bemerkt?
Ja, ich bin... ich habe so ein bisschen verdacht, ich habe gestern Abend ein Mettbrötchen gegessen.
Vielleicht war das nicht ganz frisch.
Okay, kann sein.
Wandert Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Nee, die sind schon im Marken, aber auch ja so ein bisschen im Unterbauch.
Wenn ich dann so durchfalle, dann tut es im Unterbauch auch weh, heftig, ja.
Okay, ich trage denn die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus, nur unterbauch?
Ja, das ist alles auf dem Bauch beschränkt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Husten?
Husten, ja, ich habe so ein bisschen chronischen Husten, ja, weil ich auch seit einiger Zeit ziemlich viel rauche, ja.
Ja, rauche.
Und ich weiß auch, dass das nicht gut ist, aber der Husten ist jetzt nicht schlimmer geworden.
Ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Das darf ich da nicht dran denken, normalerweise ist es dann natürlich gut, aber heute geht es mir nur schlecht, ich kann überhaupt nicht als Essen denken.
Haben Sie ab- oder so genommen?
Nee, ich würde gerne mal ein bisschen abnehmen, aber habe ich nicht, nee.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Pippa haben, haben Sie Schüttenfrost nach Schweiß?
Nein, nein, das war jetzt nur heute Nacht, dass ich mit einmal das Gefühl hatte, oh, mir geht es total schlecht.
Und ich bin dann teils, und dann habe ich mal Pippa gemessen, aber nach Schweiß eigentlich nicht, nee.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere Wäsche werden, noch andere Wäsche werden?
Also wie gesagt Bauchschmerzen, mir ist richtig schlecht, und ich darf mal Essen überhaupt nicht denken, ja.
Und ja, ich bin natürlich total, total schlapp.
Ich fühle mich so, als ob ich nur, was weiß ich, einen ganzen Tag auf dem Bau gearbeitet habe, ja.
Haben Sie vorher krankungen?
Vorher krankungen, wie gesagt, diesen Husten, das ist schon eigentlich immer so ein bisschen, und ich habe ein bisschen empfindlichen Magen, ja.
Magen empfindlich, okay.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Reizmann hat mein Hausarzt mal irgendwann gesagt, als ich da war, weil ich so ein bisschen Magenschmerzen hatte, aber ja, ich habe eben auch ganz schön viel Stress.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie da gegen einen Medikament ein?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, da nehme ich gar nichts ein.
Ich nehme nur, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, nehme ich mal Aspirin ein, und wenn ich Nacht sogar nicht einschlafen kann, dann nehme ich mal Bavariansropfen.
Bavariansropfen.
Haben Sie Schlachtstorien, ja?
Ja, so, heute Nacht habe ich nicht gerade viel geschlafen, aber normalerweise, ja, kann ich eigentlich schon schlafen, nur wenn ich zu viel Stress und Aufregung und Ärger habe, dann schlafe ich natürlich auch mal schlecht, ja.
Einschlafen oder durch Schlafstorien?
Dann kann ich vor allen Dingen nicht einschlafen, ja.
Einschlafen.
Wenn ich nachts dann aufwache, dann kann ich natürlich auch wieder nicht einschlafen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorherklampen, ja?
Nein, ich bin eigentlich immer ganz gesund gewesen.
Ja, gut.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, nein, ich nehme gar nichts eigentlich.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Nein, Operation, nein.
Ich habe die Geburt von meinem Kind, ja, aber das war keine Operation, das war keine Operation, das ging normal.
Was war das bei einem Kind?
Ja, mein Kind auf die Welt gekommen ist, das war, das musste halt, das war so eine, so eine, so eine, mit so einer Sauglocke wurde das geruht, das war ein bisschen aufregend, aber sonst,
an Operationen im eigentlichen Sinne habe ich nicht.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie eine Allergie?
Ja, ich darf tatsächlich, das hat man irgendwann mal festgestellt, kein Penicillin bekommen.
Wie räusst er sich die Penicillin?
Also, ja, damals habe ich also so gerötete Haut bekommen und die Nase war zu und dann haben die gleiche, oh, das dürfen wir nicht weiternehmen, also soll ich das immer vermeiden.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergien?
Nee, zum Glück eigentlich nicht, nee.
Haben Sie Unfälle schrecklichkeiten?
Wie, was meinen Sie?
Ertragen Sie alle, alle, was, vertragen Sie alle Medik, Milch oder?
Also, nehme ich Lebensmittel?
Ja, Lebensmittel, genau.
Ich kann nicht alles essen, was mir schmeckt.
Ich kann alles essen, was mir schmeckt, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, brauchen Sie, was brauchen Sie, Zigaretten oder?
Ja, Zigarettenraue, ja.
Wie oft brauchen Sie?
Naja, also, ich weiß, ich fahre seit einiger Zeit Taxi, also schon viele Jahre jetzt und da rauche ich fast ein Päckchen am Tag, ja.
Seit wann?
Ja, das mache ich jetzt seit 15 Jahren und vorher habe ich vielleicht mal so 10 Jahre lang ein halbes Päckchen geraucht.
Aber seit ich Taxi fahre, hau ich mehr, ja.
Da hat man oft so leere Zeit und ja.
Okay.
Wie viel können Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Regelmäßig, ja, also ich trinke schon gerne mal ein Bier und ja, aber wenn ich arbeiten muss, wenn ich fahren muss, kann ich sowieso nichts trinken.
Aber so an meinen freien Tagen trinke ich auch wohl mal Glas Wein oder ja, sagen wir, 2 Gläser Wein in der Woche und ab und zu auch nochmal ein Bier je nachdem.
Ab und zu Bier, 2 Gläser Wein?
Pro Woche, ja.
Ja, pro Woche.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, um Gottes Willen, nein.
Ich habe damit auch meine Tochter zu tun.
Das macht mir ganz viel Sorgen und macht mir ganz viel Stress, da lasse ich schön die Finger von.
Meine Tochter ist im Augenblick im Methadon-Programm und das ist das, was mir am meisten Sorgen macht, deshalb ich auch nach, dass ich sie schlafen kann.
Lebe ihr Eltern noch Mutter oder Mutter?
Nein, nein, nein, die sind beide relativ früh gestorben.
Mein Vater hatte mit 55 ein Herz in Schacht und meine Mutter hatte einen Brustkrebs und ist mit 65 schon gestorben, also die beiden sind nicht alt geworden.
75, okay.
65.
Entschuldigung, 75, Brustkrebs.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ne, ich war Einzelkind.
Einzelkind, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Taxifahrer sind.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin geschieben.
Geschieben, okay.
Haben Sie einen Tochter oder?
Ein Tochter, ja.
Das ist eben diese Tochter, die Drogen nimmt und ja, das ist mein Sorgenkind, ja.
Okay.
Aber die ist natürlich auch schon lange aus dem Haus und ich lebe für mich alleine.
Wohne Sie alleine, okay.
Haben Sie mir Fragen?
Ich bin natürlich wissen, was man machen kann gegen diese Schmerzen, wer das kommt und wann es besser wird und warum es mir so furchtbar schlecht geht.
Ja, ich denke, Sie haben ein Verdarmes Problem, vielleicht ein, ja, Verdarmes, dünn, dann Entschuldigung.
Und ist das gefährlich?
Ja, ich denke nicht, aber wir müssen weiter Untersuchung machen.
Ich werde erst mal von Ihnen ein Blut abnehmen, ja, blutabnehmen, körperlich untersuchen und vielleicht ein Urzerstall veranlassen.
Dann kann ich Ihnen genau etwas sagen.
Danach können Sie mir etwas sagen?
Ja.
Das ist ja gut, ja, okay.
Gut, wie geht es denn jetzt weiter?
Ja, können Sie, Sie warten Sie mal 10 Minuten warten und dann komme ich bei Ihnen.
Okay, dann gehe ich jetzt ins Wartezimmer und warte da.
Ja, ja.
Okay, kann ich auch eine Rauchen gehen?
Okay, dann gehen wir mal in die Rauchen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Okay, dann gehe ich jetzt ins Wartezimmer und warte da.
Ja, ja.
Okay, kann ich auch eine Rauchen gehen?
Wie bitte noch mal?
Kann ich auch eine Zigarette Rauchen gehen?
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht.
Das soll ich nicht machen.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Alles klar.
Gut, ja, schöne Frage.
Haben Sie das gelesen?
Ja.
Ja, also ob es jemanden gibt, der ähnliche Beschwerden hat, wo Sie jetzt hier gefragt.
Und, nee, nee, ich wüsste nicht, dass noch jemand das hat.
Was ist sonst noch jemand, was fragen?
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder fühlen Sie sich schwindelig?
Also, wenn die Schmerzen so ganz schlimm sind, fühle ich mich schon schlecht,
aber Herzrasen im eigentlichen Sinne habe ich nicht.
Und schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Sonst noch irgendwelche Fragen vielleicht, eventuell?
Nee, alles klar.
Wie sah Ihr Berechen aus?
Ja, das sind alles so Fragen, das will man gar nicht beantworten.
Also, Geld nicht und Essen zur Reste.
Der Rest von meinem Mettbrötchen hat mich begrüßt, ja.
Wenn Sie jetzt eine Minute eben noch zum Schreiben brauchen,
dann werde ich mal eben gucken, dass ich hier Licht einschalte in diesem Etablier.
Ich bin gleich wieder da, ja?
Ja, okay.
Das endet ja doof, mal gucken, ob ich das alles machen kann.
Ist ein bisschen doof zu gucken, ne?
Ich habe keinen indirekten Sinn.
Das machen wir auch in aller Versuch, oder?
Ich glaube, ein bisschen besser.
Ja.
Ich muss nur nur bei drei Kisten steigen.
Wären Sie so weit hier, Dr. Chilli?
Ja.
Dann legen wir los.
Guten Abend Frau Oberstin.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe eine Patientin aufgenommen, wenn Sie Zeit haben,
ich würde gern Ihnen vorstellen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, würde ich Ihnen gerne vorstellen, ja?
Okay, natürlich habe ich Zeit für Sie.
Ich bin ja im Dienst, ja?
Vielen Dank.
Es handelt sich um Frau Elke Lauter.
Sie ist seit 60 Jahre alt, wiegt 70 Kilo,
und ist 1,64 Meter groß.
Die Patientin stärkt sich,
wegen seit gestern Abend umlikale Kraft,
Entschuldigung, intermittierende,
kraftartige, umlikale, Leerbauchschmerzen vor.
Ausseht haben Sie neuser, dreimal im Messis und Durchfall.
Ja.
Sie haben, ebenfalls haben Sie auch Fieber,
das Fieber betrug 38,4.
Wann hat Sie das gemessen?
Gestern, ich habe nicht.
Ja, richtig.
Okay, gut.
Ja.
Dann haben Sie auch Adinermü,
und die Schmerzen, die Stahl ausunterbar,
und ihre Interest hat,
wurden mit 8 von 10 auf der Schmerz vermittelt.
Oh, haltet sich ein heftiger Schmerz.
Ja.
Die Patientin berätet auch,
dass Sie gestern ein Brötchen gegessen,
vielleicht nicht.
Was für ein Brötchen?
Ich habe ein Brötchen.
Ein Mitbrötchen.
Nicht.
Ja.
Wenn Sie nicht wissen, was ein Mitbrötchen ist,
müssen Sie nachfragen.
Also das ist mit rohem Fleisch.
Ja, okay.
Ich bleibe, okay.
Das Erbrochen zieht gelbig und essenlester aus.
Also das sieht geldlich aus und enthält.
Interessant, oder?
Ja.
Die werden sich vor allem bis auf Pusten,
wegen der chronischen Rauchen.
Also sie hat chronischen Husten, weil sie rauf.
Ja.
Sie habe auch in Appetence gestern.
Aber sonst nicht.
Ja.
Wenn sie schlecht ist, hat sie in Appetence.
Die Vegetative an der Messe war unauffällig.
Die Patientin hat nur Magenempfindlichkeit,
wegen viel Stress.
Sie ist eine Taxifahrerin.
Die andere vor Erkrankungen wurde verleinert.
Die Patientin nehme Aspirin und Baldrian bei Bedarf.
Okay.
Die Operation wurde, sie habe noch nie operiert.
Sie sei noch nie operiert worden.
Sie wurde noch nie operiert.
Ja, so richtig.
Sie habe auch eine Penicillinallergie.
Sie hat äußerstes Erritem und Genetes.
Was vermuten Sie denn jetzt, was sei?
Die Patientin rauche seit 10 Jahren Halbeschaft der Zykarat.
Dafür habe sie ein Schachtel geraubt.
Okay.
Sie trinken Bier, Einglasbier und 2-Glas Wein.
Bier, ein Glas Bier und zwei Glas Wein pro Woche.
Okay.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneinert.
Sie sei Taxifahrerin und geschieden, wohne allein.
Sie habe eine Tochter, die an Drogen abhängen kann.
Der Vater der Patientin hat eine Insuffizie mit 55 Personen.
Die Mutter der Patientin hat 65 Personen.
Sie ist ein sehr Kind.
Die annamnischen Angaben haben einen Entro-Qualitäts-Geschieden.
Was könnte es sonst sein, alternativ?
Die Pferenzialdiagnostik.
Die Pferenzialdiagnostik komme ich an eine Lebensmittelintoxikation.
Oder, was noch?
Was noch auch, vielleicht ein Append-Cities.
Wie gehen Sie jetzt vor bei der Patientin?
Ich muss erstmal körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Abwehrspannung.
Als Erstes, wenn Sie die Patientin angucken, was machen Sie da?
Ein Spitalparameter.
Ja, und Misspression.
Ich hau es vor, ob Sie blass ist.
Ob Sie exikiert ist.
Ja, exikiert ist.
Dann, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, wie geht es weiter?
Dann, soll ich ein Blut abnehmen, werde ich Blut abnehmen?
Nehmen Sie Blut ab? Ja, das lassen Sie untersuchen.
Ja, Blut abnehmen und Kleinstblutbild und selbe Entzündungsparameter.
Auf alle Fälle?
Ja.
Was noch?
Schutulprobe.
Ja, auf alle Fälle, genau.
Was würden Sie noch mitmachen?
Elektrolyte.
Ja, die Geld ist.
Kolorit.
Was machen Sie sonst noch?
Ich mache ein Schutulprobe-Untersuchung.
Auf alle Fälle?
Ja.
Was machen Sie sonst noch?
Ein Ultraschall.
Ja, genau.
Welche Region ist es besonders?
Besonders rechtsunter.
Rechtsunterbau.
Oberbauch und Unterbauch.
Ja, Oberbauch und Unterbauch.
Das meine ich.
Gut.
Ja, gibt es sonst noch irgendwas, was Sie vorhaben, was Sie machen wollen?
Ja, ich würde die patente stationär aufnehmen.
Fürstigkeitsruf vor.
Bitte was?
Ganz genau, wichtig.
Gleich einen Zugang legen, dass die Ordnung für sich weitkriegt.
Ja, vielleicht ein Antibiotika.
Ja, worauf müssen Sie da achten?
Aus der Penisidin.
Ja, genau.
Penisinalergie.
Und vielleicht Sipokloxacin.
Ja.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, wenn Sie so weit sind
und die ersten Untersuchungsergebnisse haben,
geben Sie mir gerne Bescheid.
Und dann gucken wir uns die Patente noch an.
Aber das wäre, glaube ich, schon gut, wenn Sie jetzt zügig in Zugang bekommt
und die Flüssigkeit.
Und vielleicht auch ein bisschen, was Sie sonst noch für Medikamente bekommen?
Was für Medikamente sollte Sie noch bekommen?
Ja.
Sie hat Kulikadien geschmerzen?
Ja, vielleicht Antibiotika.
Auch, ja.
Mit Parmillen.
Und was noch?
Vielleicht auch ein krampflösendes Mittel, ne?
Genau.
Wenn Sie keine Appendizid hat.
Ja, wenn Sie keine Appendizid hat.
Ja, das muss man natürlich erst ausschließen.
Was wäre bei der Appendizid, wenn sie akut was hat?
Was wäre dann noch wichtig?
Welche Frage?
Ah, halt.
Letzte Mahlzeit.
Ah, ja, letzte Mahlzeit, letzte Zigarette.
Vor sechs Stunden.
Ja, genau.
Sonst wird es nix für der OP.
Gut, ja, wie gesagt, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden
und dann schauen wir uns die Patientin an.
Gut, so gut.
Sie merken selber, sprachlich sind Sie nicht ganz fit.
Ja.
Sie machen ziemlich viel Grammatikfehler
und sind in besonderen Satzstellungen.
Ich habe es mir jetzt wieder nicht aufgeschrieben,
aber ich habe es zum Teil korrigiert,
während des Gesprächs, gefährlich,
wegen, wegen immer mit dem Genitiv.
Ja.
Die Deutschen machen das auch mit dem Dativ,
aber es ist unschön.
Und wenn, muss man aber den Genitiv richtig beherrschen.
Sonst über den Dativ nehmen, sonst wird es ganz furchtbar.
Ja, also wegen ihrer ähren starren Schmerzen oder ist es so etwas.
Oder wegen, wegen des, wegen des Nikotin-Konsumens.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie weit die bei Ihnen in der,
in der Prüfungssituation,
Wert legen auf Fachbegriffe.
Das ist ja ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Die einen sagen, es muss unbedingt alles mit atanischen
Fachbegriffen erwähnt werden.
Andere sagen, wie heißen Sie es auf Deutsch?
Ja, also das ist schwer, das jetzt im Vorfeld zu sagen,
worauf Ihre Prüfe achten werden.
Was wir sicherlich nicht hinkriegen werden,
ist jetzt in kurzer Zeit, dass Sie Ihre, also Ihre,
Ihre flüssige Sprache äh, deutlich verbessern.
Natürlich ist es immer einfacher,
den Fragenkatalog abzufragen.
Aber Sie haben das schon gemerkt, als die Patientin
gesagt hat, ja, was ist es denn jetzt?
Und sie dann versucht haben, frei etwas zu erklären,
da wurde es schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja.
Und auf so eine Situation muss man aber gefasst sein,
dass Ihr Patient Sie etwas fragt,
was eben nicht im Fragenkatalog dritt ist,
sondern dass Ihr irgendwas anderes will
und dass Sie dann eben schon auch das erklären müssen,
was jetzt die nächsten Schritte sind.
Und zwar eben sprachlich richtig und auch so ein bisschen flüssig.
Und natürlich dann, wie immer der zweite Teil,
deutlich schwieriger.
Ja, das ist als Erstgespräch,
immer eine viel größere Herausforderung,
weil sie nicht ganz so stark am Konzept kleben
und weil sie einfach frei formulieren müssen,
was Ihre, was die Aussagen sind,
was die Patientin oder der Patient gesagt hat.
Wir müssen das wiedergeben.
Was Sie schön gemacht haben,
dass Sie dazwischen durch den Konjunktiv,
Sie habe und sei und so,
das ist natürlich eigentlich richtig,
ist aber natürlich ein bisschen schwierig.
Fällt mir gerade ein und auf,
was noch nett wäre,
wenn Sie die Patientin durchaus auch mal
zwischendurch mit Namen ansprechen.
Ja, weil es sich gut fand,
dass Sie auf das, was Sie schon gesagt hat,
eingegangen sind.
Sie hat irgendwann erwähnt,
ich habe Stress um Rauchen und Taxifahrerin,
dann haben Sie nachher gesagt,
Sie haben ja schon gesagt,
Sie sind Taxifahrerin
und dann haben Sie weiter gefragt.
So, so etwas finde ich gut,
dass man merkt,
oh, der Doktor hat mir ja zugehört.
Ja, und das ist immer gut.
Aber bei der Wiedergabe muss man,
wie gesagt, ist es ein bisschen holprig gewesen,
eine Sache,
ja, beim Rauchen.
Beim Rauchen haben Sie tatsächlich etwas falsch verstanden.
Sie hat nämlich gesagt,
früher hat sie weniger geraucht,
aber seit sie Taxifahrt und Stress hat,
Tochter mit der Donenprogramm geschieben,
blöder Job Taxifahren,
seitdem raucht sie mehr.
Also genau umgedreht,
als wie Sie es gesagt haben.
Nein.
Umgedreht,
als wie es ganz falsch geht, überhaupt nicht.
Ich rede auch stoss,
ich bin ein bisschen mit der Entschuldigung.
Also anders, als Sie es gesagt haben.
Also nicht früher mehr,
jetzt weniger,
sondern früher hat sie weniger geraucht,
jetzt auch weniger.
Das war das Einzige.
Ja, der Vater ist auch nicht
an der Herzinsuffizienz gestorben.
Sie hat gesagt, der hat eine Infarkt gehabt.
Das ist mir aufgefallen,
beim Arzt,
sprich bei der Wiedergabe,
keine Medikamente.
Ja, was ich gut fand,
dass Sie gleich bei dem weiteren Vorgehen
körperliche Untersuchungen gleich auf die
Studieagnostik aufgegangen sind.
Und natürlich, Sie haben der Patientin das ja schon angekündigt,
die machen Ultraschall vom Bauch.
Auch da müssen Sie damit rechnen, dass ein Patient
sagt, Ultraschall tut das weh, hat das Strahlen,
dass dann noch jemand nach der
Methode fragt.
Auch da müssten Sie dann eine gut
vorformulierte Antwort haben.
Das wäre dann schön.
Gut!